c'était manuel qui en 2006 à l'idée de
planter du miscanthus giganteus en eure
et loir
une plante aux nombreuses qualités
regardez d'autres matériaux isolants
alors le choix du miscanthus il y a déjà
une question purement technique c'est
qu'au niveau de sa capacité d'isolation
on est au top de tout ce qui existe
aujourd'hui
ap taipei se régale donc j'aurais mis du
lin du champ de la ouate n'importe quoi
j'avais un coefficient d'isolation qui
était moins banque le miscanthus et le
coût de revient du miscanthus il est dix
fois moins cher que tous les autres
isolants kia sur le marché actuellement
l'hiver dernier dominique a consommé un
stère de bois pour chauffer 200 m² les
boutres d'ossature c'est les poutres en
45 220 comme ça qu'ils sont tous les 60
centimètres de boue entre les deux c'est
complètement rempli de miscanthus qu'on
voit ici dans la maquette et on a de
chaque côté un panneau de particules de
bois aggloméré 12 mm qui est par pluie à
l'extérieur et pare vapeur à l'intérieur
donc ça ça nous fait le corps du mur
quel mur porteur de la maison qui fait
tous les murs de la maison
dominique rousseau et paysagistes avant
d'utiliser le miscanthus dans sa
construction
il utilisait comme paillage cette plante
et vicard pousse des mauvaises herbes et
permet au massif de rester hydraté une
économie d'arrosage non négligeable la
société nova bio mais tu dis les
multiples usages possibles du miscanthus
nov au qcm nos objectifs c'est de
l'implanter effectivement sur des
périmètres sur des bassins
d'alimentation et de captage des bacs
grenelle
de façon à protéger la ressource en eau
si on implante du miscanthus le long de
ces vallées sèches
le miscanthus à servir de tampon
quelques pas et va donc empêcher cette
eau de ruisseler et de partir dans un
grand club
80% de l'activité de nova biomasse
spécialistes les nouvelles biomasse
végétale est consacré à la recherche et
au développement
prochain défi l'entreprise remplacé huit
chaudière au gaz par une chaudière
alimentée au miscanthus